ah it's kind of video that you might
think it's a joke it's not Photoshop you
suck at it I've seen you guys work it's
goddamn terrible and it's time for you
to learn my god before I did YouTube I
was very active on anime forums that's
right
I would get really interested in making
these anime icons or avatars in
signatures and I didn't really know how
to make them I just saw other people
having them like that's really cool I
wish I could do those cool anime so I
picked up Photoshop and it was a great
thing I really love Photoshop it's one
of my favorite tools I think it brought
me in so much in life I don't think I
would be as big on you to be something
if I didn't know how to use Photoshop so
here I am hoping to spark a little bit
of interest in case you're interested in
Photoshop by showing you how to make a
decent looking YouTube thumbnail no joke
okay
look at this by the way all of them are
gone this one I was so proud of the
Meeker one I won a competition because
of that one you know how much time it
took to animate those goddamn things and
when you don't know how to make a gif
look I got the second place in this
competition how about that first of all
you want to get the aspect ratio right
okay 1920 x 1080 put 300 if you're gonna
print that [ __ ] ass all you need to
know create there you go see so many of
you plebs have the wrong goddamn aspect
ratio now I know this is a lot to take
in in my man don't you worry this is
what you want to look at okay if it
doesn't look the same as me just calm
down take a deep breath we're gonna go
to window and we're gonna make sure we
have
lair and tools and history I am by no
means a Photoshop expert okay I'm just
we're gonna try and keep this nice and
simple
what kind of thumbnail should we make
how about a jacksepticeye now we need a
good quality picture okay all right how
about this that's a good quality copy
that [ __ ] and paste it into the
Photoshop okay
now we have our first layer Wow
incredible first of all we want to
adjust the size hit ctrl T now we can
move that [ __ ] around okay hold down
shift to keep the aspect ratio hit one
of the corners and drag that [ __ ] if
you don't hold shift you're gonna end up
like this okay what I what I tell you
about aspect ratio let's go that's right
don't get up this is too fast for your
hotcakes try to keep up what we're going
to do next is crop that mother flippa
that's right there's many different ways
to do this this is the thing what
Photoshop there's there's so many
different ways to get through different
things that you want to do a lycée a lot
of people do this they used to lasso
tool and they just drag a bunch of plebs
a bunch of goddamn plebs look at that
that looks terrible okay what you want
to do is you want to use the goddamn pen
tool okay I know people are scared of
the pen tool but it's the best tool and
if you're good like me and if you're a
Photoshop God like me it works out
pretty simple we're gonna start by
putting down a dot look at that if you
want to get rid of that you gotta hit
the leap okay you can't just dot and
then start doing other things okay that
will [ __ ] you up you once you've dotted
you can't undock unless you hit the lead
of course the pen tool that sort of
curves the lines for you and it makes it
smooth it is a little weird once you
start off but basically we'll pick a
point here that doesn't look good right
but if you hold down your mouse button
and you can drag and look at that now I
haven't just curved this line I've also
already thought about where the next
line is gonna be with this thing so if
we hit here it's gonna be nice and
easy to do another curve coming up by
better pep easy it takes a little bit of
practice you really don't have to make
it perfect it's gonna look nice anyway
just make sure here for example that you
go inside of the hair rather than too
much on the outside if you do something
you don't want you can always just go
back in history it's just too much for
your hotcakes so you can do it
relatively quickly the thing that you
got to make sure though is that you
connect them at the end so you get a
little circle coming up from the pen
tool Boop
that means it's ready to connect there
you go we have our thing what I usually
just do is right-click on the thing here
hit make a selection you can add a
feather but that's for [ __ ] I rather
do that later
now we have selected his face but how do
we delete the background I'll just hit
delete Felix nah fam look what you did
get away from here controls Zed that
[ __ ] we got to inverse the selection by
hitting ctrl shift I done now you can
hit delete
isn't that right you're wrong only plebs
delete directly okay you gotta hit the
mask button and if you do the mask
button you didn't even have to inverse
you can just hit it BAM Bam's should say
I'm on a lamb look at that now we have
the mask selected there look huh now we
have the picture selected mask selected
picture selected mask selected picture
selected if I select the mask I can
paint and [ __ ] all over and look at this
I can paint back all over Wow you don't
need to know any of this actually
nevermind now we have a jacksepticeye
look at him look at him go very happy
very pleased with this crop hey beauty
what's the next step finding a nice
looking background what should we go for
something psychedelic perhaps oh wow
this is really trippy this looks skin
copy that [ __ ] paste it now we have it
on a new layer oh my god two layers I
know this is pretty hardcore stuff what
did we learn mmm-hmm what do we learn
how do we just decide that's right ctrl
T that's right that's right and what
else did we learn that's right never
[ __ ] up the aspect ratio hold on hold
down shift and drag it border full but I
can't see Jack I
no calm down just drag the layer
underneath Jack there you go now it has
this sort of vortex sitting in the
middle right so we kind of want it to be
there but oh no we have all this space
here to the left what possibly could we
do simple trick my man press M okay
which makes the square selection select
this bit all right hit ctrl J which
makes a copy of your selection in a new
layer
hit ctrl T and then no shift this time
Pham just drag it over just drag it over
no one will know anything it will be our
little secret now we have two layers
doing the same thing we want to merge
them click on one hold down ctrl click
onto the other right click merge layers
BAM it's one unified son of a [ __ ] now
what a lot of youtubers do is they add
this like background right eh everyone
met everyone messes with the FX this
little button down here so select the
jacksepticeye layer and then hit FX
everyone does this outer glow look at
look at that wow it's so glowy and nice
but today we're going to do something a
little different
pull that range fam to the bottom okay
then megistus ice like that make it make
it dead not very spreaded about 84% look
at that that looks pretty interesting
now we're gonna do a drop shadow are you
ready
BAM and then hit okay looks pretty cool
looks pretty interesting you know it
makes it different it makes it pop it
makes it good now we're gonna add a text
go to the font okay they have old free
fonts it's really good you want
something very bold easy to read and
kind of like this you ready it's just
too advanced for you that's right you
hit T you click with your mouse you
select the phone up here look I have bad
buzz ready I suck look at that hit ctrl
a to mark your font
select the color edible all up you can
adjust click on his stupid hair and
there you go we have the same one
now press V to move that fish around
adjust the size maybe maybe going the
edges to change how it it's tilted and
stuff ok press ENTER and then we have a
pretty neat looking looking fun that is
if you're an idiot of course we're gonna
add effects on that [ __ ] now we already
added effects on Jack so we can cheat a
little bit we can hit alt and then drag
the outer glow to the I sucked and same
thing with the shadow look at that we
didn't even have to do any work my god I
actually don't really like the outer
glow I think it looks too much so we're
just gonna double click on the drop
shadow to edit it and then just decrease
it a love BAM just let just a little bit
now we're gonna ctrl T right click and
warp and then just drag and make it a
little bit more interesting okay go with
the flow you know anything to stand out
these days everyone is doing thumbnails
you gotta make them right you gotta make
the details this is advanced stuff this
is only for the pros but I'm telling you
the secrets because I know you can keep
up press Enter god damn that looks good
but I'm thinkin misses a little bit of
glow so let's go to outer glow and yeah
yeah that looks good remove the sass a
little bit you know what I'm feeling
crazy let's add a shadow again how many
shadows can I add as many as I goddamn
please mom and then let's make it spread
a little bit this is details this is
deep test hits ctrl + - zoom out ctrl +
zooms in control - zooms out now we can
look at it we need to judge from a
perspective oh look at that I can read
the fun from the thumbnail how about
that minor adjustments we're almost done
hit ctrl T adjust that son of a [ __ ]
and just that son of [ __ ] a little
bit more that's right same thing with
this [ __ ] basically what I like to do
is find fine-tuning touches when I'm
done with my thumbnail I'll create a new
layer and then I hit ctrl alt shift E
which basically merges all your layer
and creates a new layer for you so you
have that here it's really it's really
useful
Ximena Labette ctrl + ctrl T and then I
like to adjust it the cropper Labe make
it a little bit more interesting and
there you go we're done with the
beautiful thumbnail if you're more on
control you add up the saturation make
the kids want to click on that [ __ ] and
then okay look at that
saved we just did a thumbnail Oh was
this useful listen I just see all of you
make really ugly thumbnails and I hope
this helps maybe a little bit if you
have any questions let me know in the
comments I'll try and answer some of
them Photoshop it there's a million
tutorials out there of Photoshop it's
really the kind of thing that you can
easily easily self learn it by watching
tutorials and it's really fun to learn
it's really fun to create stuff I really
recommend it there's a 30 day free trial
or you can just torrent it I mean it's
[ __ ] crazy expensive let's get real
here that's all for me for now leave it
like if you enjoyed I know this is
different and in there I don't know I
don't know maybe maybe most 99% of
people won't even care but thank you for
watching anyway and squad fam out